(audience applauds)
- All right, let's close out the hour
with one last uplifting story.
This is what I'm liking.
(exciting music)
(audience applauds)
As a mama.
I would do anything to keep my kiddo safe.
I'm hardly the only one.
When one mom in Canada realized
there were no bicycle helmets
that properly fit
over her son's top knots,
she did something about it.
She designed helmets that
would fit them just right
and she's a actually also selling them
to others in her situation as well.
We have her on the line right now
watching on City TV, Toronto,
let's say "hi" to Tina.
What's up, Tina?
(audience applauds)
- Hi Kelly, I'm so excited to be here.
- I'm so excited to have you.
So this has been five
years in the making, right?
- Yeah, so about five years ago
my oldest son was five years old
and we couldn't find any
bike helmets to fit him.
We are a Sikh family,
and so my kids have long
uncut hair they wear in a top knot.
And so for that reason,
a lot of traditional bike helmets
don't fit them in the
way that they need to.
I'm an occupational therapist who worked
in the area of head injury
so I know how important bike helmets are
and you know we've tried a lot
of creative solutions to get
something to work for our kids.
We would hollow out the internal foam.
Some people go as far as
cutting holes in their helmet.
It was never quite the right solution
and I just wanted to make an option
for my kids where they never had to choose
between their identity
and sport participation.
- Absolutely. So I love
that you took action.
So how did you do it?
- Well, my husband and I
did a lot of research
and then we worked with an engineer.
Once we had our design finalized,
we got a prototype.
That prototype,
we then tried on our kids,
all the neighborhood kids,
anyone we could find who
fell in that age bracket.
And then we did more development,
more testing,
and I'm happy to share
that we just wrapped up pre-sales.
And so,
you know
my kids are excited
to have a helmet that works for them
and I'm excited that, you know
I no longer have to nag them
about bike helmets.
And it's been a real learning curve
and blessing to be able to
share with them from beginning
to end that you can take
an idea that you have
and follow through with the right support.
- Absolutely.
(audience applauds)
What a great example you are.
Thank you so much, Tina.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(bell dings)
- Oh, thank you.
- That's a rad looking helmet.
That's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
Want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
So, they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience applauds)
- Oh my gawd.
Oh my gawd, thank you so much.
- Absolutely. Thank you
for being so innovative.
It's so cool.
Thank you for joining us
and also thank you to
all our guests this hour.
Seth Rogan, Jessica Williams,
Meena Harris, and Lawrence Zarian
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.